いやーこれはこれはすごいべ
こちらに書いてある通りです
あーというわけでちょっと今回こちらはですね
精密機械なので
あんまりこれ激しく取り扱ったりしたらダメ..うぇーろれ
いてー
足の爪が取れた
うおおー
MOVRIO
多分壊れてないと思う
読み方あってるかわからないんですけど
今回こちらMOVERIOという物を買いました
いやーこれはやばいと思う
あのこれ何かと言いますと
とりあえずマジの精密機械です
皆さんあのVR
PSVRとかで意外と忘れられてるかと思うんですけど
スマートグラスってご存知ですか？
それは
なんか大体そういう感じですよ
スマートなグラス
スマートフォンというのは電話機がスマートになったスマートフォン
スマートグラスっていうのは賢くなった眼鏡
つまり次世代の眼鏡でございます
いやーもうほんとに突発的に買っちゃった
広告見てたらたまたまスマートグラスってのが出てきて
あの眼鏡かけた瞬間もうなんかね世界が変わるっていうかさ
この着けてる間のこの空間がなんか
開けましょう
喋っててもわかんないもんね
どんなんだろうと純粋に思って買ってしまいましたね
箱がめっちゃ頑丈ですもん
うわー
これとなんだろう
本体はこんな感じなんですけども
とりあえず開けてみましょう
こん中に多分入ってるな
タダノメガネ
タダノメガネデスカ？
そんなことないよ！
イヤホンも入ってます
変な充電器
これはなんだ？
うわあああ
こっちだ　こっちが本物でした
うおおうおおおやばいやばい
はいというわけでコチラが次世代のスマートグラスでございます
見たところで特に何もへんてつもないんですけども
なんかすごいっすね中が
特殊な加工になってる感
次～世代が来たぞよ
すごいぜ　これひょっとしたらVRを超えるんじゃねーか的な？
まじホント使い方も何もわかんない
ホントただけっけぇと思った勢いで買っちゃったっていう気持ちなんで
正直わからないとこある
あっあ
うわーもう完全やばい人じゃんこれ
うおおーこれ i Pod nanoが付いてますね
これを刺していいのかな？
これ大丈夫？ホント
うわうわうわうわえ、え、EPSON
EPSONって書いてある
見えますか？
EPSONって書いてあります今ここに
EPSONだ
すごいすごい　何これ何これ？
ここにE こ、ここにえっぺそんが
EPSONが、あっ消えたEPSON
これ皆さんに多分見えてないと思うんですけど
完全にMOVERIOが今ここにあるんすよ
え、すごい！
うわっす、え、待って怖い怖い
これやばいのはイヤホン付いてるんですよ
うわなんか来たなんか来たよ
なんか来たよ
全てのアプリを見るにはサークルをタップします。
はぇ？
なんなんなんなんわかんないわかんない
タッチできない
ど、ど、どうすればいいんだ　これで動かすって事？
うお、なんか動いてるよ
ここでなんかボタンがあるんだよね
これ押してみようか
なんか動くぞ
ひとまずちょっと説明書読みましょうか
動かせる動かせる　来た！
トラックパッドで　これで十字キー動かせます
ちょっと待って俺目やばくねこれ
問題はこれで何ができるかです
あっカメラだ
手が写ってるもん自分の
なんかオイラの視界の中に視界が入ってる
動画も撮れるってわけだよねー？
今、動画になってます
首の動く方向で動画が撮れてるという　ほら
カメラ、照明、照明
ヒカキンさん、所沢
で、思ったより汚い僕の部屋
こんな裏側まで全部見えるんですよ
すごいですね
今、僕はこの目の前で　今、ネットが動てます
すげー！
俺思ったんだけどどうやって伝えればいいんだろう
何にもわかんないんすよね
いや申し訳ないけど僕の目の前でしか起こってないんだよ
これ遊び方は基本的には
あぶなっ！
それは違うな多分
危ないんで座ってやりましょう
動画を楽しんだり、保存した映像を見たり、スマートフォンの映像を同期したり
あと、アプリを使ってゲームとかもできるらしいですね
これちょっと待って
これでエロ動画見たらひょっとして3Dエロ動画になるんじゃないか？
いける、いける、来た
これ、まさか...
見れるﾝ 見れる？
うわうわうわわわ
うわっエロ動画が